ready for baseball dan castano the last
time we saw him he was one out away he
was begging begging to stay in the game
team had the lead he came out after an
hour five-minute rain delay in that
start against the new york mets but
didn't finish the five innings didn't
pick up his first win so tonight could
be the let's hope it is no balls and two
strikes on bryce harper
and castano
swinging a miss
blake parker will
make the start
tonight for the fills catcher by trade a
reliever in the big leagues
and now a starting pitcher at least for
today's game and a call strike three a
breaking ball and what out here in the
first
here's matt joyce d.h here in this
second game three and two knapp sets up
outside and a foul tip swung on by matt
joyce and that's two strikeouts for
blake parker that is a nice start
on the mountain taking on jt rio muto jt
did not have a good first game
and a line drive base hit it to left
center field dickerson cuts it off
that'll hold jt to a single so jt at
first here's gene segura he swings and
grounds one through the right side
there's a base hit into right field
stopping at second is jt and so back to
back base hits put two aboard for phil
gosling here's the pitch and a ground
ball to the right side diaz gives to
the shortstop rojas who fires over to
first base and just like that they get
the double play turn nicely here's the
1-1 pitch and a ground ball sharply
struck right at rojas he has it miggy
gets it on to first for the out six to
three to end the inning and the threat
and that's a good job by dan castano
wide up in the 0-1 and a swing and a
ground ball through the right side
there's a base head andrew knapp leading
off with a single philly's let off with
a couple of hits in the second but
unable to score here's mccutchen and the
pitch on the way it's grounded right
side diving cooper it's off his glove
and he'll keep it at least in the
infield knapped down to third base and
they're on the corners with one out
first and third for reese
bouncer back to the mounds spins off the
glove of castano it's gonna allow nap to
score it's one nothing phillies that
take the early lead again that'll bring
up lewis brinson princeton getting to
start in right field it's been a lot of
rinsing against lefties he's finally
found a swing that he is trusting right
now and that
keeping himself on his backside is
giving him a chance to do just that do
that yeah that's right it's a solo home
run for louis brinson
he didn't have any last year he's got
three over the course of the last couple
of weeks
we're tied at one well he sure does and
i mean if there is a
there's no better example than the home
run we just saw that avoid sweet lou
tie up this ball game get this marlins
offense rolling he's gonna cut off a 94
mile an hour fastball look at him pull
the hands in
short quick and that's the definition of
hitting off your backside when you see
the front leg straight and your weight
on the back leg
so in a 1-1 game the marlins have
something brewing here in the bottom of
the fourth an error and a single men at
the corners nobody out for east san
diego
and diaz left field that's going to get
down an rbi single for east san diaz
marlins take a two to one lead diaz
rojas and brinson now your runner
that'll bring up jorge alfaro the middle
of the field right center field in big
situations ground ball base hit up the
middle for alfaro in comes diaz miggy
right behind him throw his cut off and
alfaro does it again
now jorge picking the same lane he
picked last night for the game-winning
base hit does it once again with the
bases loaded and oh by the way a
breaking ball just like last night and
brad boxberger now the pitcher for miami
therese lined out to center his first
time
out toward right center field that's
pretty well hit and that's going to
split the gap and go to the wall and
terrais will go to second base
and that is where he'll stop and the
phillies need some base runners and
they've got one to start here in the
fifth andrew mccutchen the hitter
mccutchen lofts it to left center that's
not deep it's going to drop for a hit
read beautifully by tires he'll score
rbi single for catch it's a 4-2 ball
game he's the over seven with the bases
loaded in his career he's got the bases
loaded here with two men down two two
to first cooper
gets it to box burger and the marlins
get to the bottom of the fifth so a
stolen base for harrison two balls one
strike on starling marta martay base hit
right field here comes harrison around
third harper throws
not in time an insurance run on the rbi
single from starling marte in a safe
situation here for yimi garcia's close
in late situations that's the seventh
inning or later in games that are
separated by one run or less
the numbers for garcia unbelievable so a
two out hit for harper
and jt rio muto will back back toward
the middle base into center field
harper's around third heading for home
the throw to the plate by marty is cut
off and it's a 5-3 game gene segura is
coming up he's one for two with a single
and a walk two and two swing in a miss
strike three it's a marlins win
they split the double header and take
two of the first three from the phillies
a 5-3 win